no we're not you not you don't just know
this woman know that you know you I know
you want to be like the Jane Goodall are
[ __ ] animals of dogs and stuff but
you're not that you're a hoarder okay
and this is your way of like getting
meat because you know that if I get
emotionally attached let me tell you
this if I get so emotionally attached if
I had children and they did something
awful in society like you know when I'm
gonna set Jeffrey Dahmer's dad you know
was a biocide even during the trial and
and and in prison visited a man he loved
his son Jeffrey I'm that guy
what if you're Jo my son Aled me what if
our child killed me I'd be so sad he's
our kid your blood well let's say he had
meant to kill you but accidently shot me
and killed first of all how does that
happen yeah how does that happen because
like I went like I bodyguard like Kevin
Costner dyou you know I sort of like you
know how the bullet was like about to
hit Whitney Houston well if he tried to
kill me and he killed you then obviously
doesn't like me so I would not be on my
side but if my son was like stand by my
side even though I ran over ninety
Mexicans yeah you know in a truck I just
be like all right I love you dude you
know whatever you need yeah right or no
you what you should you see your son is
six years old he did something a trust
atrocious yeah in society spawn of the
devil and I'm sorry I birthed him what
if it's like I ran over them and I liked
it dad well let's go through that
commerce and I'd like to do it a young
guy know I met Linnell we're at that
little we're at the Q book of the
visiting center where they have the
glass thing I like that with the phone
yes I think that always put the hand up
like that okay yeah yeah all right so
what's say son what would be what why'd
you run over that family Jack we put our
heads that why you smiling all the other
enjoy it first of all could you see this
we're doing this little sketch right now
yeah number one you don't laugh come on
don't break
and you put your hand on the [ __ ]
window alright so I'm gonna first don't
when I'm gonna first walk in so you
don't put the hand out you put the hand
on there when I put alright so go ahead
now put the hand down now son
dad what you runner with a family trying
to be honest yeah I [ __ ] liked it dad
your hand but you take it out for a
second no it was a bit shocked
no it was hurting I can't keep it up
that long I have fat hands sorry yeah
they just weigh a lot my arm hold up it
really does burn now yeah do that it was
no because we don't have a window to
place it on we're doing a mime window
hurting so bad
it burns yeah so next time we do the
thing we have to put away that I love
the sound of bones crushing know at that
point I go my son that has something
wrong but if my son said dad I don't
know what happened if it was an accident
or if he killed like actually was a
serial killing in a mental disease I
don't want to be doing what I want to be
doing I have a disease you know then I'd
be like all right you get the booty
juice every day and you [ __ ] I
chained you to like you know how they
did in like that one zombie movie with
Simon Pegg where like his his best
friend
basically chained to his basement and he
fed him every day because he loved him
that's what I would do let me ask you
this what if this happened we were like
at a dog park go be bit you know I mean
a kid's hand the kid loses the hand
loses because he gets an infection about
their intense bye and then they say we
have to put Kobe down I would definitely
plead with a family because nobody
they'd know that we you plead we did
everything know we're putting it down
what would you do
I would probably try to smuggle her to
Mexico well there you go you have the
heart to yeah that's all I mean that's
all
no because like riot okay so you have a
- you have it - you have the love thing
- of course I do especially if like
we've had okay if everything leading up
to my my child being a murderer is like
good memories and like he's always been
a good kid and he showed a lot of love
but then one day he just snapped and
then he [ __ ] killed a lot of people
then I would be like okay something is
like really wrong with my son that needs
help but I know that deep down he has a
goodness in him now if he had shown
signs of pure evil from the day he was
born
yeah I'd be like yeah you know what I
see a son yeah I'd be your next victim
you know what's interesting is the kid
that a half asian kid in San Bernardino
what's his name only you mean in Santa
Barbara Santa Barbara I mean yeah Elliot
yeah the response of his parents which
was was actually the right it's the only
response I've ever saw saw that I went
okay that's the only way to go what was
it the dad I mean you know he was a
director or assistant director right he
felt so shamed by it that he met with
other family members apologized
profusely Wow he went on a lot of news
programs and he was a very distraught
and I mean he went he did everything he
could to try to relieve you know relieve
the you know their pain although you
can't do it but you have to try you know
like you see other parents they
disappear that you don't see or hear
from them at all like the dad from
what's the Chi the kid that or Virginia
attacker I know Virginia for a Sandy
Hook that dad when did when did you see
him ever you don't know what he sounds
like they just disappear they get off
you know but it's like I feel like it's
your responsibility as a parent to do
everything you can to apologize and it's
it's partly your fault is it not or no
I've seen I've seen really really
horrible children come out of great
parenting though
because that's what I fear with us if
I'm being honest I feel like there's
gonna be an element of genetics that's
gonna override our good parenting
because we come from a very violent
family don't even [ __ ] know babe our
kid is gonna be pure Basquiat it's super
all right our kid is gonna be a street
hoodlum heroin shooting artistic junkie
our kid is going to you know being a
band like the Sex Pistols and die right
away but still he's gonna make a mark
our kid or either he gets into science
like you with your science he head yeah
yeah I mean and he like develops like a
cure for sickle cell I mean or Crohn's
he developed he develops a potion where
when women get Crohn's
he doesn't seep into their vagina like
sometimes the poo does is that guy goes
for your chai I'm real high goals are
you kidding me if you actually like he
could fix a fistula yeah yeah yeah
that's called being genius I'm okay with
that with him but then he did but he's
weird and he hangs himself whatever
whatever he might don't wish that on
your child no one I'm just saying that
it's like when we have a kid that's also
a part of having a kid it's like it's
like buying a lottery ticket
I think successful parenting is like
just me see what happens like just make
sure that you keep him alive if my kids
alive and not hurting other people like
I'm like okay I've done my job I think
because you just don't know sometimes
it's like yeah but you don't you like
look look at uh who's a prime example
who's that kid that I know he's an actor
he's in transformers chaila chaila
chaila booth doesn't him
yeah Shia LaBeouf shadow booth yeah you
see booth Shia LeBouf I know his dad
right he's just like a hippie long hair
kind of like almost borderline look he
looks almost homeless he used to do open
mics with me oh really oh yeah his dad
you still he was at this long-haired
really tall gangly dude who now lives in
last time I heard he was living in like
a side house that Shia was bought or
whatever yeah but like you know DiCaprio
comes from hippie families you know you
don't you don't know what you don't know
what's gonna be the combination to
create I know we get it man George keeps
texting him
[Music]